[Musique]
[Applaudissements
] plus d'écriture,
plus de rodéos si tu n'arrêtes pas tes
crises vont s'aggraver
[Musique]
Je suis Phil Gus prêt je ne peux pas nous vendre
ce n'est plus comme si tu pouvais le monter
tu as vu  la vie
tout le monde il est allé trois pour trois et
cool Junction le veut ouais comment est une bonne
nuit pour les retardataires parfois les rêves ne sont pas
censés
être  où vas-tu avec
ça oh tu n'as pas besoin d'y aller aujourd'hui
je suis un nerd et je roule va
te tuer alors
[Musique]
c'est dommage que ta mère ici toi et
elle puissiez être têtus ensemble
je crois Dieu  donne à chacun de nous un but
le pire est juste de l'autre côté de la Prairie
[Musique]
quatre Cowboys - bien
[Applause]
toi